binary tree is a common data structure
used in software development.
It's also a frequent topic and technical coding
interviews in this course, Alvin will explain
binary tree algorithms and prepare you to use
them in both interviews and coding projects.
Hey programmers, Hamilton from Shruthi, elk to
our course on binary trees, I want to show you
how you can do well on those technical interviews
that have binary tree problems. So what I have in
store for this course, like usual, we'll go over
both the theory pines and binary tree algorithms,
as well as of course be more practical and come
up with a code implement those algorithms really
a one two punch. For every section, we're going to
be sure to draw out a pictures and visualize and
truly understand the algorithm on the whiteboard
notes are feeling comfortable with that,
we'll go over to the code implementation.
So in the description and in the timestamps,
you'll be able to find the corresponding exercise,
you can practice every algorithm that we go over.
In terms of the prerequisites for this
course, I'm going to assume that you're
not new to programming. And maybe you've dabbled
in some previous data structures and algorithms.
And you're also familiar with some recursion.
But that being said, I'm going to assume you know
nothing about binary trees, and even just trees in
general. with no further ado, let's jump right in.
So first order of businesses, let's actually
understand what the word tree even means. And
like the programming concept, right. So when we
visualize a tree, a tree contains many nodes,
typically we draw nodes as circles, right. And
these nodes can also point to other nodes. So
here I have one node. And I could point to some
other node, right, I could point to any number of
nodes. So here are the circles, I'm going to refer
to them as nodes, and the lines or hours between
them, I'm going to call edges, right. So this is
an example of a tree. And trees can of course,
come in many different shapes and sizes. So here's
quite a large tree. Let's try to understand a few
terms we can use during our technical interviews.
And this is something I highly recommend, right?
helps if you speak the language, it does show
that you have proficiency dealing with the data
structure, we could store values within the nodes
of our tree. For now I'm just going to put some
letters. When it comes to your programs, you can
store any type you want, you can store integers,
numbers, or even other objects. So because we have
a tree, we like to use familial relationships. In
other words, I think of like a family tree, right?
So if I look at node B, let's say I call them the
parent. If b is the parent, I know that children
of B are just the D nodes, right? their parent
and child is like a relative relationship. Let's
say I kind of changed my frame of reference. And
let's say I looked at a as the parent, well, that
scenario, then B and C are the children of a. for
the case of the C node, if I think of CSM parent,
it only has one child, its lone child being the F
node. So feel free to use that parent child
relationship when describing the relationship
among nodes within a tree. Another terminal is
a lot in the context of trees is the word root,
right? So a root is going to be a node that has no
parent. So in this tree, A is the root because a
has no parent, right? There are no arrows going
into the a node. On the flip side of that,
if I look at the nodes in DNF, we call
them leaf nodes. A leaf node is a node
that has no children, right, so d and f have no
outgoing arrows. Typically, in a binary tree,
we're going to have a single root and we could
have many leaves. One thing I want to be sure to
do is make sure you generalize your understanding
of a leaf, right? So in this particular example,
looks like every leaf is two edges away from
the root, counting the number of arrows from
the roots, any leaf, it could be the case that
my leaves occur at different levels, right? So
I removed that F node, which case C is now a leaf,
right? Although a C is on like a different level
than D and E, it's not the bottommost level, it
is the case that it's still a leaf, right? a leaf
node is just a node that has zero children. All
right. So with all of those terms out of the way,
let's hone in on the real topic here. Right,
I talked a lot about trees. But really in this
course, I want to go over the basics of binary
trees. Right? So let's look at that binary part
to begin with. That's really a dead giveaway.
We know binary has to do with the number two.
A binary tree is a tree where every node has at
most two children. Right? So currently on the
screen, I have a binary tree. If I gave a another
child, let's say a third node over here of f,
this would be a tree but not a binary tree. Right?
It would be like a ternary tree because I have at
most three children. So let's say I kind of remove
that extra node. Now it's back to a binary tree.
And it could be the case that a node has less
than two children but still be a binary tree,
right? So if I gave C, just a child of f, this is
still a binary tree. It's if I look at any node
within my tree, that node will have 01 or two
children, and no one has more than two children,
right? So you want to be sure to remember that
a node in a binary tree could have less than
two children. All right. So I'll be the first
criteria for understanding what a binary tree
is right? It's probably the easiest criteria and
most children per node will also want to be sure
to add into our definition Have a robust
understanding is to also remember that,
at least for us in computer science, we think
of our binary trees as having exactly one root,
meaning there should be only a single node that
has no parent, right? Typically when we draw,
it would be like the topmost node. So right
now this is definitely so far a binary tree.
If I had some other node in this drawing,
like G, right, g also has no parents,
I would no longer consider this a classic
binary tree, right? So watch out for that.
Let's go on to our final criteria, we also need
one more ingredient. And that's exactly one path
between the root and any node, right. So looking
at my example to the left, this is indeed a binary
tree that meets all three criteria. And let's say
I chose the root and any node, obviously, there's
only one root, so we're definitely considering the
a node, let's say I chose some random node like E,
this is really a binary tree, then we're
guaranteed to have only a single path that
connects A to E, a path is really just a series
of connected nodes I can travel through, right,
so to get from the root a to the node E, I
can go from A to B to E, and that would be
one path. And that's the only way to get from
A to E. That's what I mean by exactly one path.
Let's say I chose another node like F. There is
also exactly one way to get from the root to F,
and that's just a CF, that would be the only path.
If I added some additional connections or edges
within my tree, I can get a scenario like this,
this would no longer be a binary tree. For one,
we can see that B has three children, but also
does not have a unique path between the route
in any node. For example, if I chose a and the
note of f, one way to get there is by going ACF.
But another way to get there would be a, b, c, f,
right? And so do watch out for all three criteria
when you're considering a binary tree. Awesome. So
let's look at some smaller examples. And this is
where I think some students tend to struggle with
their understanding of binary trees. So if I took
out some nodes over here, this would definitely
still be a binary tree, right? Just looking at our
different rules, right? Let's say the root node A
only had one child would still be a binary tree,
right? Because the binary tree only demands that
we have at most two children, we still have one
root, and we still have only one path from root
to any node. Let's say I have the smallest tree
that has a node, which would be the singleton
tree, this is still considered a binary tree,
right has one route. And there's not really any
pass to be had here except the route to itself.
And every node does have at most two
children. Here we have zero children, right?
The final edge case we want to think about
is what happens when we have no nodes,
right? We consider this as the empty tree. This
is a very special case. And we should consider
any empty tree as actually being a binary tree.
That's going to be very useful when we come up
with some algorithms later on, right. So a common
edge case off to consider is what happens when we
have an empty tree, that's a tree with zero
nodes, right? Let's look at another example.
Let's say I had this structure to take a moment
look at it, and see if this meets our criteria.
This would not be considered a binary tree. So
we look at your different criteria. Looking at
the first one, it does have at most two children
per node, so that's okay. But we can't identify
exactly one root here. Remember that a root
node is a node that has no parent, right?
If you look at every node in this picture, every
node has exactly one ingoing arrow. So that means
every node has at least one parent,
right? So it doesn't meet that criteria.
And furthermore, there is not exactly
one path between the root and any node,
because we have a cycle within the structure.
So for example, let's say I was starting at a
right and I wanted to travel to see, one
way to get there would be to go A, B, C,
that'd be one path. But I could also have another
path or I just go around twice and go A, B, C,
again, there would actually be an infinite number
of paths in this scenario. Because of that, this
is definitely not a binary tree. And there kind
of many reasons for that. If I had a different
example, looking at this one, now I need criteria
one and two, right, I have at most two children
for every node. But I also still have exactly
one root node here I would consider z the root
node. However, there is not one path between the
roots in any node and because I have that cycle.
So these rules are really worth remembering,
they're really going to help you solve a much
more difficult binary tree problems. And if you
remember these three rules, you can identify
different problems in a binary tree framework.
In other words, the hardest problems that you'll
encounter in your interviews are problems
where they don't tell you straight up what
data structure you're dealing with, you're just
gonna have to notice the pattern. In other words,
what if I gave you some structure like this, take
a moment and figure out if this is a binary tree.
If you look closely, this does meet all
of the three criteria to be a binary tree.
I can just treat a as the root because it has no
parent. I can treat nodes D and F as the leaves
because they have no children. I just drew
this in a pretty interesting way. Right? If
you really range things in a classical binary tree
sense would look like this. More importantly, this
has the same relationships as a previous drawing,
I just show it in a top down fashion, right? So no
matter what do you understand these three rules
for a binary tree, right? Because sometimes may
not be as explicit as a nice triangular shaped
drawing. Awesome. So we've talked a lot about the
theory of how to, you know, look at and reason
through some binary tree definitions. Let's
go ahead and start to talk about how we could
represent binary tree programmatically. In other
words, how can we do this in some code? Well,
no matter your programming language of choice,
I think you're going to represent these as
objects. In other words, every node here is
going to be some objects. So it could be like an
instance of a class, the properties only to store
within this object would be the current value. So
I need something to store like the A of my current
node. But I also need to refer to some children.
So we'll also need some left and right pointers
to the children, right, those are just going to
be some properties on that object. In a classic
binary tree is very common to refer to the
two children using a left and right direction.
Notice that some nodes here, like the C node,
they're only going to have one child, right? c
only has a node dot, right? It does not have a
left. So we're gonna have to use some empty value,
like null or undefined. To represent a child that
doesn't exist, right? Especially for a node like
he, he has no left and also no, right. So here's
what we'll do, let's go ahead and hop into my text
editor. And I'll show you how you could represent
a binary tree programmatically. So transition,
here we are in my text editor. Let's start by
creating our node class, right. So you'll be able
to follow along any language that you choose,
I'm going to do mine in JavaScript, right. So
I think the best way to present a node is just
to use some class. So hopefully familiar with
some classic class syntax, let's create a node
class, there's going to be a quick constructor,
I think would be valuable to take in the initial
value that's going to be stored within the notes,
I'll take the ns a constructor argument, I can
just set this dot Val to that value, and also need
two more properties, one for my left, so I can say
this dot left, I'm gonna initialize it to null,
that means by default, a node will have no left
child the same way. By default, a node will have
no right child, right? So when you use no to
represent children that don't exist over here,
awesome. That's all you need to create, you know,
a baseline binary tree, right, we're going to use
this class a lot during the course to test our
algorithms. So I'm going to create a node and
eventually wire up a tree. Well, I'll just call
my constructor few times, I'll create different
nodes, I'll just store them to some variable
names. And of course, a new node to create
new instance of node, and I'll store some value
inside, I'm going to store some characters inside,
I'll create a bunch of these different nodes,
what we'll want to be sure to do is make sure
that you also set their pointers properly. So
I'll give each of these some different values ABC,
D, E, also do F. And then I'll just manually
for now set their pointers properly.
So what if I did syntax like this is since I'm in
JavaScript, I can easily assign these pointers,
I can say, A's left is going to be B. I can
say A's right? is C can also say B's left D.
and then B's right is E. And maybe Finally I can
say C's right is F. So by doing these assignments,
I'm connecting some nodes together, I should
end up with a structure like this right? Have
a as a root, because nothing points to a
it has no parent. But a has two children
of the NC. And then along with
that, B has two children of D and E.
Finally, C just has a right child of f, this is
actually the same tree that we looked at a lot
during the whiteboard session, right? And
that's how you can represent that same tree
programmatically, right? So I always think it's
valuable to also try to visualize your trees,
right? Obviously, we created this tree in a very
manual way, probably in the long run will create
applications to just maintain and create trees
dynamically during some input. But for now,
we'll start by creating all of our
trees in this very kind of static way.
Right? And so with that, now that we have an
understanding of how to represent a binary tree,
let's go head back to the whiteboard. And
I can show us our very first algorithm.
Hey, programmers, Alvin here, right? Now I want
to go over this depth first values problem.
So this will be a good review of the depth first
traversal algorithm. So what do you want to do in
this problem? Well, what we want to do is take in
a binary tree, and in particular, your function is
going to take in the root of the binary tree.
And just recall that given the root node of a
binary tree, we know that that node is going to
have pointers to its left and right children,
which may point to other nodes. However, if let's
say a node does not have left or right child, then
its point is going to be set to No. So that's how
I represent our binary tree programmatically. But
for now, let's just stick to the visual represent
of our tree. So for a depth first traversal,
we could start with the root node of a, what we'll
do is we'll just add that to some collection.
And we're going to have to maintain these in
a very particular order. And then from there,
according to a depth first traversal, I could
go to B. And here's where we make our really
important decision, right, we can either go to
C, or D, if I'm doing a depth first traversal,
I need to go deeper in the tree before I move
laterally. So that means I go from B to D.
And once I bought them out at D, there's
nowhere deeper, I can go from D. And so now
I move laterally to the E node. And this pattern
continues, right? I don't have anything deeper
from E. So now I go to C. And then from C, I go
to f. So this would be a depth first traversal
on this binary tree. Notice that it goes A,
B, D, E, C, F, and again, the really important
characteristic is we must go deeper in the tree
until we can't anymore and then we can go across
the tree. That being said, How can we actually
managed to implement this algorithm. If you're
familiar with depth first, traditionally, then we
know that it's going to use a data structure like
a stack. So let's get situated over here. So we'll
trace through that again. But this time, taking
a really close look at how we can use a stack to
accomplish that direct order. And so just recall
that a stack is a sequential data structure where
we can only add things to the top of the stack
and remove things from the top of the stack.
So a really important characteristic is
we can't really insert or remove elements from
anywhere but the top of the stack. So when I add
things to the stack, I was added to the top like
this. When I remove things, it's also from the top
like this. Alright, so when I begin at this
depth first traversal algorithm, I'm going to
start with the root node of a. And by default, I
really just take that root node and I just store
it on my stack. So it's the only thing on my stack
right now, I'll use these rectangles represent my
different stack frames. And really in my program,
that would just mean storing the actual instance
of node or some pointer to it. Cool. And then
from there, I actually begin my main algorithm.
So the main flow of a depth first traversal, we'll
check if the stack is empty. Right now the stack
is not empty, because I have at least one element.
And so what I do is I start by removing or popping
the top element of my stack. So I'm gonna remove
the A, and I'll label that as my current node
being explored. And when something leaves the
stack, then I can consider it being visited right
now. So I need to list out my values, because
that's the whole point of this problem, right?
So by now I've just visited the a node. At this
point, I can look at that nodes children now.
So I look at the a node in the tree, and I see
that it has a B child on its left and a C child on
its right. And from there, I push or add those two
children to my stack. So I'm going to put c first,
and I put B afterwards. And notice if I push my
right child first, followed by my left child,
that makes it such that my left child is
at the top of my stack, which means that
I would hit them next. And that actually ends on
my first iteration of this depth first traversal.
And now I asked that same question is my stack
empty, it's not. So I removed the top of my stack,
I'll call it B, my current, which means I could
print it out or insert it into my values list.
Nice. From there, I consider B's children,
B has two children. So I add them both,
I push E, followed by pushing D. That ends that
iteration. Now something interesting happens,
my stack is still not empty. So I know I removed
the top, so I call D, my current, I add D to my
list of values. But if I look at these children,
it actually has no children, right, and so there's
nothing to add to the stack from here. And
so technically, I finished this iteration.
And now I still have stuff on my stack. So now
I pop he off the top of my stack. Same thing
as before, right, I add to my values, he has
no children. So I'm done with that iteration.
Finally FC, I removed C from the stack, and I
printed out in my values. And then at this point,
I see that the C node only has one child, so I'm
just going to push the children that exists so I
would push the F node onto my stack. And that's
a really important thing to remember when it
comes to implementing your depth first traversal
you're going to have to check if your children
exist before you add them to your stack. And now
on the final final iteration, we have the F node
we remove it from the stack, we add it to our
list of values f has no children. And so I finish
this iteration and now my stack is empty and I
will just exit right once the stack is empty. I
know that I must have traveled through the entire
binary tree. So there we have it and we do get the
correct output over here. So just by using a stack
and just obeying the rules of the stack, that is
we got pushed to the top and removed from the top
we will get the correct order. important thing to
remember is you should add your values into your
like values list whenever something leaves the
stack. That being said, What can we say about the
time and space complexity of this algorithm? Well,
it's actually pretty straightforward. Let's say
we define n as the number of nodes in this binary
tree, then we can say that the time complexity of
this is O of n. And why do I say that? Well, we're
just going to add that every node eventually to
our stack. And that nodes also going to leave the
stack exactly once. So it's not like we're double
visiting any of the nodes. So I'm guaranteed to
just run in O of n steps. In a similar way, we
can see that the space complexity is O of n,
the only thing we stored was really the
stack, which is a linear data structure.
And we know that we're not going to put ever
more than n things on the stack. So overall,
we have a linear time and space solution for
this depth first traversal problem. All right,
I think we have a good understanding about the
approach for a depth first traversal. Now let's
go ahead to the walkthrough video. And we'll
implement this one in a few ways together. Hey,
programmers, Alvin here, right. And I want to go
over a JavaScript solution for this depth first
values problem. And so we're going to do here is
really just implement that same strategy that we
traced through in the approach video, pretty much
to the tee. And we'll start with the iterative
version. And that means of course, we will solve
this one in two different ways, right, we're gonna
solve it iteratively first, and afterwards,
we'll go ahead and solve it recursively.
Alright, so let's jump right in over here. Like
we said, in the approach video, we know that the
iterative version really relies on us creating a
stack. And for most of your programming languages,
you can just go ahead and use your like array
data structure for that. So I'm going to use
just a plain old JavaScript array, I'll go ahead
and name this one stack. And we can just use
an array to represent a stack as long as we stick
to two particular methods, right, I'm going to use
array push, which adds to the end of an array,
and also array pop, which removes from the end
of the array as well. So I'm going to consider the
end of my array to represent the top of my stack.
Cool, we'll go ahead and do is initialize
the stack with the root node on top of it.
Nice, then I can have my main loop for the
algorithm. So we know that we need to keep
running the algorithm while there's stuff on our
stack. So I can just check while stack dot length
is greater than zero. So while I have
at least one element on my stack,
there is some work to be done here. And that will
step through a single iteration of this algorithm,
we know that we start interation by just
removing the top of our stack, in other words,
stack dot pop in JavaScript, that will also return
us the element that we just removed. So I'll call
that my current const current. And that is going
to be an instance of nodes, it's going to be
one of these objects. Cool. So now that I
remove this element from the top of my stack,
let's say for now, I just I don't know,
print it out, maybe we'll kind of debug
this one as we go. So console dot log, current
dot Val, because I know that every instance of
node has a dot Val prop on the inside. And then
from there, I need to add this nodes children.
So you might go ahead and guess that to do that,
we could just do stacked up push, I'm going to
push the left child, one out here, so node or
current dot left, followed by the right child.
But we also need to make sure that these
children exist, right? Look at the prompt.
There could be instances, for example,
like this C node over here, this C node
only has a right child, but has no left child,
right. So what I don't want to do is push C's
left, because that'd be pushing no onto my
stack, which would give me an error later
on. Right? So I want to only push the children
if they exist. And I need to individually check
if the left exists and push it and also if the
right exists and push it, I'm just going to
add some guard statements for both of these. So
we'll go ahead and insert will say, all right,
if the current has a left and right side, current
dot left, called justice for the right hand side,
cool, maybe we can inline this, if you prefer.
Alright, so I'm going to only push the children
if they exist. And that should actually be the
heart of our depth first algorithm. So we're not
putting our values inside of an array like the
problem asks, but we should at least be able to
see the correct order of printing here, because
I'm going to print a nodes value as soon as it
is removed from my stack. So I'll go ahead and
actually maybe bring in maybe one literal test
case, so I could just steal this little stub over
here. And this will just print out the values.
Right, so I'll test this I can hit Run, if
I hit Run, it's just going to execute this
file just like a script. So it's not
going to run any automatic test cases,
just going to run my file as is. So if you want
to test it in this way, kind of in a manual way,
you're gonna have to be sure to call your
function. I do have a console dot log on
the inside. So I'll just run Run this manually.
And when I do that should see some output here
looks like node is not defined because I forgot
to bring in my class definition. So I'll do that.
give that a go. Alright, so looking at our output,
we didn't get our exact depth first traversal,
like we expected, right? I got ACF, B, D, if
you take a look at what we really printed out,
we technically did print out a depth first print,
but we favored the right hand side. So we did a,
c, f, and then B, E, D. So let's say we really
wanted the left to right version of this,
and all you have to do is flip the order that you
push the children, right, it should be clear by
looking at these two lines, right? When I add
my children looks like I push the left child,
and then the right child. If you push the left
child first, and then you push the right child
afterwards, that means that the right child's
going to be on top for the next iteration. So
if you do it like this, this will favor the
right hand side and travel through it first.
But if you did it like this, now you'd be
actually iterating to the left branch first,
toward the right. So with that small change,
let's just see what our print is. And there
we have a nice AB de ECF. However, in this
problem, they want us to actually return
those values in an array. So I can kind of
get rid of this little Manual Test over here,
I don't need this class definition anymore. And
now instead, I'll just gather up all of my values
in some results array. So I'll say, maybe result
over here starts as an empty array. And then as I
pop elements from the top of my stack,
instead of logging them, I'll go ahead and do
result dot push, and I'll push that value into the
result array. Once I'm done with this while loop,
that means my entire tree has been explored. which
case I can return, make sure I spell it right,
return my results. Cool. So this should be a
nice solution, it's actually run the test cases
on this. give that a go. So it looks like we're
doing pretty good. But for this very last example,
looks like we're getting can't read property
Val of na, and that's running test case 04.
So if you actually go into the prompt, those
test cases are actually laid out explicitly
over here. So I want to go to zero for now
let's look at the zero for test case. They go
ahead and they pass my function, no, right kind
of representing like an empty tree or an empty
node. And we can kind of trace it what happens
here for our code. Let's say that root was null.
That means when we initialize our stack, our stack
literally contains like a null value. So it's not
even an instance of note just now. So that means
when I entered this while we're going to check,
you know, Do I have anything in my stack, and
I do because my stack length is one. And then
when I pop, the top element of my stack current
is going to be no, then on this line 14 it says
null dot Val. And that's actually where our
code explodes, right on line 14, right? You
can't reference property Val, of null. And so
to handle this scenario, we want to make sure
that we actually never allow anything No, to enter
the stack. It's kind of why we had this guard over
here. mentioned also be true for even the top
level route, in case they give us the empty tree.
kind of seems like a corny, you know edge case.
But this is a pretty common one, when you actually
go into your interviews, right? What
happens if you have an empty input.
And so I'll just guard that explicitly,
I'll go ahead and check, hey, if my route,
so if my entire tree is empty. So if route equals
null, then what I'll do is just return an empty
array, right? Because that means there are no
values inside of it. And that actually is the
expected answer, according to this, right should
return an empty array. So let's give it a go now
should be pretty good. Nice. And there,
we have our nice iterative solution for
this depth first values problem. Alright, so
here's what we'll do. That was one solution.
Let me show you another way. let's implement
this. And that would be our recursive flavor.
So I'll just kind of redefine it down below. And
I actually recommend practicing both versions,
because they're going to serve as like the
basis for which you solve a lot of different
tree problems. And so when I think about the
recursive version, like all of our recursive code,
I must think about the simplest case of my
input, and that will act as my base case, right?
So in the case of a binary tree, the simplest
tree you can be given is going to be the empty
tree or just a no root, right? So it's not even
going to be about a node that's single node right
inside of a binary tree. It's going to be about
an empty tree, right, a tree with zero nodes. I'm
going to check if my route is no, and I have an
empty tree. And I think about this base case, as
if it's its own input, because it really is right
and so if someone They asked me to give them back
in array of all the values in the empty tree, it's
still the case that this must be an empty array,
right? Because there are no values,
there's even any nodes and the empty tree.
And then from there, I can generate my actual
recursive call, right. And I know what I call
my stuff recursively. That means I have to
reference a function and again, go ahead and
invoke it. And I'm going to call upon root dot
left, as well as root dot, right? So this would,
this call over here would give me back an array
containing all of the values in the left subtree.
And this will give me an array of all the values
in the right subtree. And so let's say I see these
into their own variables respectively, you don't
have to do this part. But I'm kind of a fan of it,
especially if it's the first time implementing
this. So I'll call this my left values.
I'll call this one my right values. And here's how
I'm able to kind of quickly create recursive codes
all about taking when I call is a recursive leap
of faith here. So let's say we're stepping through
test 00. And so this is our tree visual, right?
So we know that our root is going to be a node.
So when I actually make this top level call,
this base case does not fire. And so I make my
recursive calls, right? I know when I do depth
first value, or values, rather, let me fix that
depth first values of root dot left, that means
I'm going to be passing in the B node, right,
and here's how I have to actually pretend my code
behaves, I'm just going to get back the correct
result from this call, right? So if I passed
in the B node into this call, what I expect
back is the full array representing the depth
first traversal of that subtree, starting at B,
right. So if I got correct data over here,
what it would look like is just B, D, and E.
That would actually be the full depth
first traversal, from this subtree,
right. And I'm kind of doing that just mentally,
or I know the expectation for this algorithm,
it's going to be a similar story for my right
call, right? If I'm at a So A is still my route,
and I passed in my right child See,
to this call, what I expect back
is just an array of CF, which would be the
depth first traversal of that left subtree.
And now that I have, you know, my left subtree
values and my right subtree values, I have to
think about how to combine it all together, right?
How do I work myself into that output by combining
both of the results from my children, right, what
I need to do is really just take myself put it in
the array, followed by my left children, followed
by my right children. So I can do some nice
JavaScript syntax for that whenever returning
the right when I throw myself in there, so I'm
going to throw in a root dot Val, that's myself.
So that'd be like the a node that I just take all
the values in my left result, put them in here and
just use the spread operator to unpack that array.
And I'll do the same thing for the right values
of CF, right. So dot dot, dot, spread out right
values just so I return a single array, and this
pattern itself does match this output, right,
kind of taking the leap of faith and assuming
correctness from these recursive calls over here,
right, I have a, and I plug in substitute B, D, E,
and then for the right, I have CF. And even before
we run this, I'm not going to, you know, assume
too much JavaScript knowledge. So maybe you're
kind of new to this spread operator. So
in general, super quick aside over here,
let's say had an array of some stuff. So I'll
say, peeps there and some people over here.
So we'll throw in fleabay, we'll throw in Jason,
throw in Raj, throw in heavy. And what I can do is
whenever I have an array, I can just use a spread
operator to kind of unpack that array. So for
example, I can say const will say new peeps. And
I'll create a new literal array. So whenever I say
square brackets, it gives me a new array
literal. And what I'll do is, I don't know,
put an element at the front, we'll call it Alvin.
That'll spread out the elements of peeps, right?
So just imagine I took all of the elements here
and just remove the brackets. That way I don't add
any initial nesting. And then at the end, I don't
know I can add someone else. Like, right? Well,
console dot log, what new peeps looks like so I'm
not gonna run the test cases, we're just gonna run
this file as a script, just so we can review this
spreads index. So if I give that a go, we kind
of make this bigger. Notice that I have correctly
spread things out right? Have Alvin at the front,
and I have all of the things from peeps in the
middle, right, followed by Brian at the end.
So you can do this. You can also use like the
concat method on arrays. You're probably going
to see me use this spread syntax a lot because
I'm kind of a fan, right. But with that in mind,
let's go ahead and actually test this code. So
we'll run all the test cases. Nice. And this
is another working solution for our depth first
values. And it should be pretty natural that we
can solve this problem also recursively. So I know
that the iterative solution for this depth first
traversal requires a stack data structure.
And I know whenever I write recursive code,
under the hood, your programming language is
actually going to track all those recursive calls,
using the call stack, right? That call stack
behavior gives you the same type of ordering,
which is really convenient. Cool. All right.
So before I send you off on the next problem,
I want you to actually practice both solutions
for this depth first values code, it's going to be
very necessary to actually master some later
concepts that are coming right up. So do spend
some time on this practice makes perfect,
right, and I'll catch you in the next one.
Hey, programmers, Alan here, right? Now I want to
go over this breadth first values problem. So it's
really just going to be a little variation off of
the depth first one we just did, of course, but
it's really important that moving forward for all
of our tree algorithms and other data structures,
that we have both versions down pat. So in this
problem, we're going to take in a binary tree,
once again, very classic binary tree structure,
this time, I want to return an array or a list
of all the values according to a breadth first
traversal order. So a breadth first traversal
starts with the root node of a, so that's
nothing new. And then from there, I could
go to B. So right now I have my a node, and also
my B node. And here is where we diverged from our
previous problem in a breadth first traversal. And
breadth just refers to like the width of something
I travel across before I go deeper. So in our
breadth first traversal, I'm gonna move to C
and not D for now. So I add my C node c value to
my list. And then from here, once I finished this
entire level, and there's nowhere to go across
the tree anymore, now I could go downward to the
next level. Now I have D, and then E, and then F.
So they're really important distinction here is
the breadth first traversal starts with
ABC, whereas the depth first traversal
would have started A, B, D. That's a
really, really important distinction.
And so how can we go about implementing
the breadth first version of this?
Well recall that the depth first used a stack
data structure, well is the case that the
breadth first is now going to use the queue data
structure, really just the partnering version
of that structure. And so let's kind of step
through that in a more programmatic way. So I'm
going to use and track my queue. And just recall
that a queue has no sense of direction to have
the back of my queue and the front of my queue,
things enter the back of the queue, and they leave
the front of the queue. Right. And so no one gets
a skip line either. So this gives me a nice fair
ordering, think of a queue as just like waiting in
line at checkout at a grocery store or something.
So how do I begin my algorithm, I'm going
to start by initializing my queue with the
root node. So I'm just gonna start with a on my
queue. And then from here, now I can begin my main
algorithm. So my main algorithm should check
on every iteration is my queue empty, right now
it's not because I have at least one element.
And so I remove the front element of my queue.
And so we know that a would be removed,
and we label it as our current.
A node being explored when something leaves
the queue and is marked as our current will
say that now it's being visited. So I would add a
to the running list of my values. Then from here,
I need to look at his children. He has two
children B and C, I need to go ahead and
add them into my queue. And so let's say I
added B into the queue first, followed by C.
Notice that C must enter behind B, right. And
now I finished this iteration. At this point,
I have the next iteration of my algorithm, I take
the front element of my queue, and it leaves,
right So b is now my current, I add B to my
running list, then I look at B's children of D,
I push D followed by he behind it. At this
point, I have another iteration to do right.
And it's so on so forth. From here, see leaves the
front of my queue, I add it to my list of values,
and I look at sees children see only has
one child. So for that child that exists,
I go ahead and add them to the back of my queue.
And it's really important that I added to the back
right at this point had my next iteration. At this
point I continue, my queue is still not empty, so
I still have some stuff to remove. So D leaves in
front of my queue, I add it to my list of values.
Since D has no children, there's nothing to add
here. next iteration, he leaves the front of my
queue, I added to my list of values, no children,
so I don't need to add anything. And finally f
leaves the front of my queue, I just add it to my
list of values and again, f has no children. So by
now my queue is empty, which must mean that, hey,
I must have completed the algorithm, right? There
are no more nodes to explored, I explored and
added every single node to my list of values.
All right, and this output actually looks correct,
right, I get abcdef, just like we say. But what
about the complexity of this algorithm. So
let's take a closer look over here. Well,
we know from the get go, that n is going to be the
number of nodes in this binary tree. So that will
be the term for our sides of input. And we can say
that the time complexity is simply just O of n,
roughly, because we know when it comes to visiting
these nodes, and you know, using our loop,
we're going to add every node to the queue once,
which also means that that node is going to leave
the queue also wants, so it's not like we're
double adding a node to the queue, right,
we're not going to double visit any of these. In a
similar way, the space complexity is going to be O
of n at most, because, you know, we're just going
to add at most to all of the nodes into our queue.
And in general, it's probably going to be less
than Oh, event space in terms of how much space
we use in our queue. An important thing I'll
just mention right now that in regards to the
time complexity of this one, here, we're going
to say that the time complexity is O of n. And
that's if we can assume that adding something now
to the queue runs in constant time. And removing
something from the queue occurs in constant
time. So depending on how you implement this,
if you use actually, a built in an efficient queue
data structure, you will get this O of n time
complexity for our breadth first. But if you use
a less optimal, like data structure, maybe not a
perfect queue, then you might have an actual worse
complexity. So again, this time complexity of
O of n assumes that we have a maximally efficient
queue that has o of one add and remove operations.
With that being said, I feel pretty good
about coding this one up. I'll catch you
in the walkthrough video, and I'll show you a
few different ways that's implement this one.
Hey, programmers, Alvin here, right now I want
to walk through the JavaScript solution for this
breadth first values function. So hopefully,
you just finished the depth first version,
in which case, this one should be pretty much a
cakewalk. But of course, we will still go through
the motions of it, because it's going to be useful
to solve much harder problems later on, as you
always hear me say, Alright, so to tackle this
one, we'll start with our queue data structure,
right? So nothing fancy in JavaScript, what I
would do is just use an array and just stick to
using very specific methods, right? So I'm
going to create an array, I'll call it my
cube. And we're going to initialize that queue
with the route on it by default. And we'll also
guard against upfront is imagine they gave us
an empty tree to begin with. So in other words,
the initial route is no, which case it would
be like this test 04. And they just want us to
return an empty array. So I'm going to guard for
that explicitly. So I'll check Hey, is my route
No. And if it is, just go ahead and return an
empty array like that. Nice. Then from here,
I need to start in my main loop from algorithm.
So I iterate a while my queue is not empty,
just like we spoke about in the approach video,
right? So while q dot length is greater than zero,
then keep on going. Now I begin a single iteration
of this algorithm by just removing the front
of my queue, right? So it's really up to you which
methods you use, you just need to make sure you
remove from one end and add to the opposite end.
So for me, I'm going to treat index zero as if
it's the front of my array, I'm going to treat
the last index as if it's the back of my array,
right? So if I want to remove the front and say,
array dot shift, or for me right now, Q dot shift,
that removes the front also returns to me, that
element, so I'll call that my current note,
x. And then from here, I need to add this node
children into my queue. And that'll give me my
main flow for this breadth first traversal.
Right. So I'm going to go ahead and check,
hey, if my left child exists, so if, let's
say current dot left, that is not know, then
what I should do is go ahead and push that into my
queue. So I'll say q dot push my current dot left,
and it's just going to be symmetric
for the right hand side, of course.
So if the right exists, then push the
right into the queue. Just like that.
Awesome. And so that looks pretty good. And
then from there, I actually want to store
the nodes I visit in an array for the
final return just like the problem asks,
so nothing too fancy. I really want to insert some
code over here about and so I'll create a result
array, I'll call it values, sort of empty whenever
something leaves the queue. I'll just take that
and push it into my values. So I say values dot
push. I'll push that current Val into my queue.
And do note that, what you can't do is just take
like the queue and treat it like your final return
value, it must be a totally separate thing,
right, I use the queue just for the sake of
traveling through in a breadth first order. And
the order that you visit is actually derived from
the order in which things lead the queue.
So that's why I'm doing it over here, right,
as soon as something leaves a queue, that's what I
considered visited. So I added to my values list.
Nice. And after my while it's done running,
I'll go ahead and return my entire values array.
So let's give this a test. I'm gonna
run all the test cases, what we get,
have a few test cases to pass. And there we
have it. Here's a nice iterative solution for
our breadth first traversal. Just something I want
to mention, by the way, let's look at the prompt.
So looking at, I don't know, like the very
first example, in this kind of rendition of
breadth first, what they asked us to do is
really give us a breadth first traversal,
that moves from left to right, so notice it goes
A, B, C in terms of the resulting output, and
not a CB, right, those would both be technically
correct, start to a breath first. And then you can
kind of choose depending on what problem you're
solving, whether you want to go left to right
or right to left. For me, because I push the left
followed by the right, that means the left is
going to leave the queue first, right, because
remember, the queue is just like a line and
checkout. So if someone enters first, that is the
left enters first, they going to be served before
the right go. And you can just flip these around.
And I'll give you the right to left universal
goal. So depending on what your problem warrants,
you can always manipulate that code a little bit.
And this is actually probably like the only
solution you can have. You know, maybe aside
from just some superficial changes to like the
code style, this is going to be your go to and
only go to solution for a breadth first traversal
on a binary tree, right? A common mistake I see
people try to do a lot is there is not really a
straightforward way to implement a breadth first
traversal recursively. And that should make
some sense, because a breadth first traversal
needs a queue order right needs to use a queue. If
you write any recursive code, you know, under the
hood, it's using a stack. And so that stack versus
queue is really just going to fight against you.
And you're going to have a really tough time
trying to implement the correct ordering.
So always just writes the iterative version
for your breadth first traversal. Alright, so I
recommend before you hop into the next video, make
sure you're able to write this code on your own,
because we are going to level up difficulty a
little bit, but I'll catch you in the next one.
Hey programmers, Alvin here, right now I
want to walk through the approach for this
tree includes problem. So the premise of this
problem is I'm going to give you a binary tree,
and also a target value to look for. I
just want you to tell me True or false?
Is that target value found within the binary
tree? So for this particular example input,
the answer is obviously true or Yes, right, you
could definitely find e within this binary tree
for give you another target value like
j, you would respond with false, right?
Because that value j is nowhere to be found within
the binary tree. And really what I'm asking you to
do here is we're stepping through the canonical
like breadth first search and depth first search
problems. And I think I'll walk through both
approaches for you right now. So let's say I
was testing or I wanted to trace through rather of
the input where target was IE, how can I go about
attacking this one, right? We know that in
most of these problems, when they give you
a binary tree as input, they're only going to give
you really the root node. But that being said,
if you have access to the root node, then you know
you have access to all nodes that comprise of the
tree, right. So what I can do is just perform any
of my traversal algorithms. So maybe to get going.
Now let's just do either the breadth first search
or the depth first search iterative style. So I
think for this trace, I'll stick to the breadth
first version, which means we're going to use a
queue, right? So as we trace through this, I'm
thinking about this one iteratively. Right now,
hopefully you recall from our previous problems
when it comes to your breadth first traversal,
you start with your root node on your
queue. And when something leaves the queue,
you mark it as your current right. And here's
where I work in the new logic for this,
this particular problem. When something leaves
the front of my queue, I'm going to check Hey,
is that current value the same as my target value,
so is a the same as E. It's not. So I have not
found the thing I'm looking for, right? And what
I can do is now consider his children. Right? So I
look at his children. They both exist, I add them
to the queue. So I'd be to my queue that I add see
to my queue. And now I'm on to my next iteration
right? The front end element B leaves a queue,
and I have to check, hey, is B, my target,
it's not right my target t. So I keep running,
I look at B's children. So I take that D and
added it, I take the E and also add it. And this
process just continues, see leaves front of my
queue is see my target, it's not. So keep going,
I would add C's children to my queue. So I just
add F to my queue. And this process continues.
And so d leaves the front of my queue I check is d
my target, it's not, and D has no children to add,
right? Recall that in our breadth first traversal,
I only add the children if they exist, because I
don't want to add any, like null pointers into
my queue. And so I just continue my algorithm,
right, I still have stuff in my queue to check.
And finally, when he leaves the front of my queue,
I check Is he my target. And indeed it is right at
this point, I've just confirmed that he is found
inside of my binary tree. So what I can do is just
end my algorithm by like returning the true value,
right? There's no point of actually looking
through the rest of the tree, because I already
figured out that, hey, my target value is indeed
within the tree. Right? One thing you might notice
is, it looks like I only checked for IE once
it left the front of my queue, and not when it
was initially added to my queue. Technically, you
could have returned early when you added it to the
queue. But we'll kind of see when I walked through
the full code for this one, it would end up with
cleaner code if you just checked for your target
value when something leaves your queue. So we'll
see that when we go through the code. It's just a
small implementation detail. That being said, for
this iterative breadth first strategy, what can
we say about the complexity? Well, if we define n
as the number of nodes, then we know that the
time complexity is just O of n, it's really just
a classic breadth first traversal. So nodes
are going to enter the queue once and leave
the queue once that's open, right. And again,
that's considering if we use a efficient queue,
right, where our queue add and remove operations
run an O of one constant time. So we have linear
time. And for the space complexity, it's also
going to be O of n linear, right? Because we're
just going to store our nodes within the queue.
And so we just looked at the approach for a nice
iterative breadth first solution, not to this
problem, but I want to show you the depth first
version, and the depth first version, that would
be recursive, right? So obviously, you could write
the iterative debt per solution, which case you
just use basically the same code we just spoke
about, but just use a stack instead of the queue.
But let's try to solve this one. recursively,
right. And the reason I think it's really
important to expose yourself to recursion like
this is, as we move to more complex topics, you're
going to find this style of recursion. Very, very
useful, right? So we have the same input, right?
Let's say My target is E, and I have the same
binary tree. And now I want to check recursively
is E within this tree? And so how do we start
attacking this? Well, we're going to need to think
about our base cases, right? So we're gonna have
really two types of base cases, we'll have
like the affirmative base case, meaning Hey,
we found a match. And so whenever I counter a
node, whose value is he, or whose value matches
my target, then I'm gonna have that node or that
recursive call, return true, right? So that's my,
like, affirmative base case. So I'm just gonna
plug that return value in visually in my tree,
you know that this II nodes gonna return true. And
now I'll think about my negatory base case, right?
Four times where I call upon an empty
node, or the null node, I should return
false. And recall from our previous lectures,
we said that we're going to sometimes represent
explicitly our null nodes. So I'm going to fill
those in, for example, the C node in my picture
would have a left child that is null. So I'll kind
of draw that one explicitly. And I know that a
node like that is going to return false. Because
logically, I shouldn't be able to think about
all of my recursive calls as if they're their own
subproblems. Right? So if someone asked me, Hey,
can you find this E value within an empty tree?
Right? a null node represents an empty tree?
The answer to be no, I can't find the value in
an empty tree, because there's nothing there.
And so from there, I'm also going to draw
explicitly all of those similar null nodes,
null pointers, right? So it looks something like
this. Notice that from the E node, I don't need to
give it a null left and right, because I already
said that that node is going to return true,
right? So that's why I draw my tree like this.
And I have all of those false return values.
Cool. So we just labeled all of the base cases,
right as the leaves of our tree, and recall that
a leaf is just a node with with no children,
right? And from here, how do I actually combine
all of these Boolean values to get the true at
the very top, I know for my top level color,
that is at the a node, or the a recursive call,
I need to get back that value of true, right?
And the logic we should use is really just
to the logical OR so how does this one work.
So let's start evaluating our return values and
combining them at the parent. So this should be
somewhat of a similar pattern to like the tree
sum problem I showed you. And so what you could do
is focus on this D node over here, this node has
values ready on its left and right has two falses.
And when it actually gets those falses returned to
it, it just should do the logical OR so it's doing
false or false, which evaluates to false, right?
Which means that hey, in this subtree rooted in D,
I cannot find the value, which makes sense. That's
why it's false. I'll continue this process. If I
look at this B node, now this B node has values
ready on its left and right. And they're going
to bubble up a little bit. And I take the order
of them so I do false or true, which evaluates to
true. And this process continues everywhere in the
tree, right? So at this f node, false or false, is
me false. At the C node, false or false gives me
false. Finally, at the top level root of A, I do
true or false, give me back a final true, which
is indeed the correct answer. So hopefully,
you realize how similar the solution is to our
previous tree some problem right in the tree,
some problem, I combined my left and right,
child return values by doing the arithmetic
addition. But this time around, I just need
to use the Boolean operation of or right,
so by just adjusting the type to Boolean, we
have a very, very elegant solution that shout
out George Boole. And so with that, I think let's
go ahead and implement this one in some code,
and I'll show you it using the interest of
flavor or using maybe a breath for us, and also
the recursive version, which is my personal
favorite, using this recursive tree structure.
Hey, programmers, welcome back. Alright, and I
want to go over a JavaScript solution for this
tree includes problem, right? Well solve this both
depth first, and also breadth first. And I think
we'll start with the iterative breadth first
version. And so this is really just going to
be implementation of the classic breadth first
search algorithm, I'm just gonna lay down my
classic a breadth first traversal code, and then
just add some conditional logic afterwards, right?
So you should be familiar with it by now. But for
my breadth first traversal, I'm going to use a
cube. So I'll say const, q equals an empty array,
are really an array with the route thrown on the
inside. And from there, I have my main algorithm,
right, so I loop while my queue is not empty.
So while queue length is bigger than zero, and
keep on going. And on a single iteration of this
traversal, what I do is Q dot shift, so remove
from the front of my queue, the front of my array,
remove the first element. And I'll save that into
a variable called current. So that will be just
an instance of node. And for now all why don't
I just build up my solution slowly, I'll just,
I don't know, console dot log, what current
dot Val is. But once I consider this node,
what I want to do is really add its children into
my queue only if they exist, though, right? So in
general, I'm going to write like q dot push,
I'm going to add to the back of my queue,
so I get a nice cue order, push the left child,
so current left, likewise, the right child.
But imagine that I have an asymmetric node or
just a leaf node, right? Something like C would
only have a right child, so it's left would be no.
So if current is see, then I'd be pushing No, into
my queue as the left, which is no good, right. And
so I need to guard here and only push the children
if they exist. So something like this, hey, if the
current has that, corresponding left and right,
then I can go ahead and push it. So this is
looking pretty good. And that should actually be
the main traversal part of the code. So I'll
just test this manually. So very manually, so
maybe just this call, so I'm not gonna return
Booleans yet. We'll build up to that. But I
should at least see my values printed. If I kind
of run this manual test case, I'll bring in my
node class, I should see the values printed in a
correct breadth first orders, that means A, B, C,
D, E, F, recall that breadth first traversal
travels across our tree before going lower,
so I must finish a level before traveling to the
next level. So let's just run this manually as
a script. See what we get here. A, B, C, D, E, F,
nice, so I'm getting the right order of traversal.
And now I can work in I think, the conditional
logic because they want us to return Booleans
over here. So pretty straightforward stuff. We'll
go ahead and check once something leaves the
queue. I can check If the current nodes value is
equal to my target, then I've found the thing I'm
looking for. So just return true, right, you're
done, you don't need to travel through the rest
of the tree because you can return true. But on
the flip side, if my value that I'm currently at
is not the target value, that I must continue
looking through the rest of the tree, right.
So if I finished the entire while loop, that means
I've traveled through the entire tree. And I never
found the thing I'm looking for, I should return
false. So I need a late return false over here
are really common mistake people tend to make is,
what you don't want to do is just do like, else
return false here. So this is going to be wrong.
Right? Because this would only check like the very
first notice normally check the root, and then
check if the root is not equal to the value.
If it's not, you just return false, which is
not really useful, because it could be somewhere
else in the tree. So you're gonna need that late
return false pattern over here. But with that, I
think we're going to pass some of the test cases,
as well run the test cases by hitting that test
button. And there's probably one scenario we
did not for C. Cool, and there it is, right? Can I
read property value? No, we're failing tests. 055,
look at that spec. Test five gives us a null
node as a root, right? So just the empty tree,
you cannot find the B character inside of the
empty tree. So return looks like false over here.
And so I can just handle that one explicitly.
I'll go ahead and check at the top. If my
route is no, right, if that's the case, then just
return false. I can't possibly find any target
in an empty tree. Right? The reason our
code was failing before is if root is null,
then I initialize my queue with no. And when
that thing is pop, and that null is popped,
or rather shifted from the queue in the first
iteration, then I check null dot Val, which
is an illegal JavaScript operation.
So I'll run all these test cases now.
Nice. And there, we have our breadth first
solution for this tree includes problem.
All right, now let's work on the recursive depth
first version of this, it's actually my personal
favorite, because it utilizes a pattern that I
think is quite elegant, and one I use a lot for
much more difficult problems. So like we said,
in the approach video, if you haven't watched
the approach, you definitely want to check
it out. For this recursive version, right?
what I should do is check Hey, if my root is
null, if I have the empty tree, basically,
then just return false, right, because I can't
possibly find my target and empty tree, right,
that's just a given. And from there, I know I'm
going to have the general shape of some just
depth first traversal code, which means you call
the same function because it's recursive. That's
what recursive means. And you pass along your
route dot left and a separate call your route,
right. And when I should be sure to do
is Don't forget to pass in your target,
write the target that you're looking for, it never
changes. And I know that these two these two calls
are going to give me back boolean data. And I
know that the Boolean I get back from like this
call would represent whether or not I found the
target and that subtree, right. So this gives me
the result of if I found it in the left subtree.
Or the result if I found it in the right subtree.
And I can just do the logical OR on both of
these, right. So if I find it in either subtree
then return true. So I could just write in line
return true over here, right? So let's say it's
in my right subtree, then this left hand side
invites to false. And this is true, in which case,
this entire thing evaluates to true. And let's
say in a bad scenario, let's say it's not found in
either subtree. So this evaluates to false. this
right hand side also evaluates to false, false
or false gives me false. However, one thing I need
to be sure to add is also an additional base case,
after I check if my route is no, what I want to
do is then also check, hey, maybe this route I'm
currently at, maybe it actually has the target,
right? So if route value is equal to the target,
then you're also done, except you can return
true. Cool, and that was very reminiscent
of our approach video. So let's give this a shot.
You should be able to pass nice, and I love how
clean this code is. I will admit, you know, it's
pretty tricky. If you're not a fan of writing
recursion, in which case, I'll totally convinced
you into being a fan of recursion. But notice how
kind of clean this code is really leverages
recursion. One very important thing I want to
bring up is it's really keen that I put this
base case on line 26 after the null check,
right? So let's say I flipped the
order of these. Let's say you did this.
I believe that would not work out always because
it assumes that you even have a route Alright,
so I'm feeling a test 00. But in general, if you
look at this code, let's say that route was no,
right? You're gonna start by checking
null dot Val, and I'll throw an error,
right? Can I read property valve? No. So you want
to actually always lead with your base case that
checks if your root is null, right? Because that
should guard really the entirety of our code. So
this is actually the code you want. Over here.
Alright, programmers. So that's all I got for this
tree includes solution, I want you to practice
both versions, and I'll catch you in the next one.
Hey, programmers, Alvin here, right? Now I want
to go over the approach for this tree sum problem.
And so in this problem, I want to take in a binary
tree, just like we've been doing as of late,
this time, the values within the nodes of this
binary tree are going to be numbers, right,
what I want you to do is compute the total sum of
all the values in this tree. So for this example,
we should end up with 25. And so hopefully, you're
kind of gathering how to attack this problem,
especially given you know, the algorithms I've
been showing you as of late. So if you've been
studying our problems, and are there hopefully,
you know, a straightforward solution to solve
this one, we could of course, just use any type
of traversal algorithm. So we can use either a
breadth first or a depth first traversal. And we
can just add all these values into a running sum.
And of course, we probably initialize that sum
to zero, right? So the iterative breadth first
or depth first solution, I think, is very
straightforward, right. And I'm not going
to really step through that approach with you
over here, I think you have that one down pat,
especially if you've done the previous two
problems. But what I will show you here is
actually how to solve this one recursively, which
would be a type of depth first traversal, because
we know that hey, depth first traversal relies
on a stack. And if you do something recursive,
it is utilizing the underlying call stack.
So I will get a similar type of ordering.
And so when we trace through this type of
solution, this recursive solution for this tree,
some problem we're going to do is try to be
very explicit, I think this is really helpful,
especially if you struggle with recursion,
right? So given this binary tree, I know that
for particular nodes of my tree, like the four
node, it does not have a left child, right. And
I know like programmatically, what that means is
like that nodes dot left pointer points to like,
no, or it's a null pointer. And so I'm just
going to draw that explicitly, sort of like this.
Again, they'll just help us really understand how
our recursive code performs on this type of input.
And so if I know that I can put like
an unknown load to the left of four,
then it could be the case that other nodes like
the leaves have to in one, they also have both
left and right children that are also know. So
if I drew all of my null pointers explicitly,
it would look something like this. Cool. And this
is really something that helped me really get
comfortable with recursive problems, especially
those on binary trees. And what we're doing now
is, we know that when it comes to solving any
problem recursively, it's about writing a base
case, that is like the simplest version of our
input. And here, I'm going to argue that our
base case needs to be about the null node, right?
The null node basically represents no node at all,
or represents the empty tree in a sense. In other
words, if someone asked me to calculate the sum
of a null node or the sum of an empty
tree, then to me that some would just be
zero, to write elegant recursive code
to try to think about your base case
as a problem in itself, right? So if someone
gave me an empty tree, that is a null node,
I would return the total sum of zero. And what
that means is I know that all of these null nodes,
they would return zero as their computed sums.
Nice. And then from there, how can I use this
information to actually build up my main solution?
Right? So let's go ahead and target this for node
to the left. And what I have to do is figure
out Hey, know what is this subtrees total sun,
and I can compute that given the values
to the left and right. In other words,
if I return those two null values returns to zero.
Now I just have to do zero plus four plus zero,
which just equates to four, right? And that is
actually correct in itself, right? So what green
number above a node represents the total sum
of that subtree. And so it is a case that, hey,
the total sum of that four node is just four.
And I would do something similar for this node
over here, right? When these base cases return
to their color or return to their parent, I just
have to add my left and right child together
along with myself. So zero plus two plus zero,
gives me to not do that same thing. For this note
11 We're here. And now things get interesting,
right? It's a calculate the total sum rooted at
this 11 subtree, I would just return these values
to the top. And now I do four plus 11 plus two,
which gives me an answer of 17. And if you do a
quick spot check, right, this 17 does represent
the total sum, just in this subtree, right,
and we'll carry on over at this one node, we know
that this is going to return just a value of one.
And now at this four node, I can compute its total
sum. And recall that this four node had a left
child of zero, right? Because it has a null node.
And so when I compute the sum, I get five, which
is perfect. And finally, at the main route, now I
bring up these two values. And I compute 17 plus
three plus five. And that gives me a final answer
of 25. Which is indeed the correct answer. Right?
So that's how we should really think about our
recursive algorithms for our binary trees, right?
I kind of draw it out, I think about the
base case, which is typically not always
but typically about the null node. And then from
there, I figured out how a parents can compute
its result given its children's answers. Alright,
so if we take a look at the complexity of this,
it's pretty straightforward. We'll go ahead and
define n as the number of nodes in our input tree,
in which case, I can see that my time complexity
is just O of n, right? We know that we're going to
make a recursive call just for every node of the
tree. And we're not going to call duplicate nodes,
right, we're going to have just one call for every
single node. And within any single node, we're
just going to do some simple arithmetic, right, we
just had roughly three numbers together. So it's
not like we're going to have like a loop inside
of our calls at all. In a similar way, we'll say
the space complexity is O of n, just because we
have that implicit, a call stack space, because
we are going to solve this one recursively. And so
we're solving this one in O of n time and space,
which would be actually a maximum efficient a
solution for this problem. And so with that,
I think, let's head over to the walkthrough
video, and I'll show you how to code this one up.
Hey, programmers, Alvin here, right? Now I want
to walk through the JavaScript solution for this
tree some problem, I think this time around, and
I'll jump right into the recursive version, right?
So we'll start recursively. And we'll begin with
our base case, right? My base case is always about
the simplest version of the input, where
I just know the answer without needing
any additional calculations, right? I know
that the simplest tree here that I could be
given is going to be the empty tree, right? I
have the empty tree. That means my root is no.
And if your root is no, you have the empty
tree. What is the sum of the empty tree? Well,
kind of inherently, it's just zero. So I'll
be my base case. Nice. And then from there,
I'll think about how I can compute my answer,
given my children results. So I need to find
the results of the some of my left subtree.
And also the some of my right subtree. So
just call recursively. So tree, some of root
left, as well as tree some of root. Right?
Cool. And I know that these two calls, they return
numbers, right, representing the sum of my left
subtree. And the sum of my right subtree. As the
parent that is so rude, how can I find my total
sum? Well, it just is myself. So root out value,
plus everything in my left subtree plus everything
in my right subtree. Right. And we'll go
ahead and just test this out the gate.
But this is nothing fancy, really elegant code
to look at the test cases here, we do have some
a diverse output. So this code does work on trees
of all different shapes and sizes. Something that
helps me you know, really believe the magic of
recursion is to just analyze the assumptions here,
right? So let's say that I'm stepping through tree
some and my root is this three over here, right?
So I checked the base case, is this three node?
No, it's not. So I must make the recursive call,
right. And I know that when I break down this code
recursively, I know my route that Val is going to
be like three, so I'm kind of corresponding, this
comment with the thing below, right? And then
when I make the recursive call on tree, some root
dot left, that means I'm asking for the total sum
of this subtree starting at 11. So I'm looking
at the 11 for negative two subtree. Right,
if I take the total sum of just that left
subtree, it looks like it's going to be just
13. It's now I'm saying plus 13 over here,
right? If I do the same thing on the right,
subtree I know that this call is for this
four node, right all of its children,
that should just magically return by the
power of recursion that should return
five, right? I'm going to assume
that that recursive call just works.
So you're out the five, right? If I take the total
sum of these, three plus 13 1616 plus five is 21.
That would give me the correct answer, right.
So to have some confidence in my recursive code,
I just write the code. And then I assume
correctness from my recursive calls. And
I figure out how I can take those sub valleys
for my children, combine it with my own value,
and that should be my final answer. So here
is the recursive version of this solution,
which would be some sort of a depth first
traversal, technically, because it's recursive.
And if you'd like, I can also show you the
iterative version. So let's just do that.
And I always practice usually my problems doing
both the recursive as well as iterative version,
if it's reasonable, and is really reasonable
here. Hopefully, you're familiar with
our breadth first code by now, right? So I'm just
gonna start by checking, hey, if you're given some
root that is already know that that's kind of an
edge case, I'll just go ahead and return zero,
right? Because as some of that empty subtree,
or that empty tree, rather, is just zero,
that can begin my main code. So while my
queue is not empty, so I'll start with a Q,
who begins with the Route Route, I want to loop
while my queue is not empty. So while q dot
length is bigger than zero, I'll begin a single
iteration of my while loop by just shifting out
the front of my queue. So in JavaScript, for me,
that's q dot shift that removes the front element,
and also returns it to me. So I'll save in
current. And then from there, now that I have
this current, I know that contains the value
that I actually care about. So what I would do
is go ahead and track some running sum. So I'll
say let some member say let total sum equals zero.
And as I remove something from the front
of the queue, I'll take it to value
and add it to my total, something that will
accumulate all of the values right into a
sum. And from there, I just need to add my
classic logic of checking for my children,
right? If they exist. So if I have a left,
so if current dot left is not equal to know,
then what I'll do is add that left child into
my queue. So q dot, push my current dot left,
again, make sure you're following your cue
rules, right, so shifts removed from the front,
push adds to the back, it's really important that
my shift and my push or my add and remove methods
work on opposite sides of my queue. Otherwise,
it's not a cue, right? So that looks good to go.
I'll write something symmetric. For the right
hand side over here. By the end of my function,
I'll just go ahead and return my total sum.
Nice, this would be my go to enter diversion.
course, it's technically a breadth
first, and we'll give that a test.
Nice. And here we have that solution. So one
thing to note, I think it's pretty important to
be consistent how you implement these algorithms,
I swear possible. So you'll notice that I always
am a fan of a writing my like processing logic for
a node. Here I consider like the processing logic,
where I add the value of my current node into
my total sum. I do that processing logic,
typically when a node leaves the queue, and not
when the node is added to the queue, and just ends
up being less repetitive that way, for example,
I've seen some people write code like this,
where it's like, Alright, well, you know, I guess
since I'm adding my left child into my queue,
that means it exists. So not only will I push it,
but I'll add it so I'll do I don't know total sum,
plus equals current dot left dot Val, right, so
I'm kind of adding the child's value as soon as
it's added to the queue. And you can write
something symmetric for the right hand side,
you can see that because of this, I kind
of have to double up all of my code,
which does not make it super clean. And I think
something that is even worse than that is well
now you actually never added your root value
into the your, your total sum. So you'd have
to begin your total sum as root dot value at this
point, I'm like, I kind of just hate this code,
right? So you can run this, this would probably
work. So this code totally works, but it's not
what I think is the best design for this pattern.
So I'd rather write it like this, right? consume
your values when they leave your queue because you
know, eventually, everything's gonna leave, right?
So I'll prefer it at least like this. Cool.
So before you go on to the next problem,
recommend you practice both versions. I
know of this problem. So do it recursively
do it iteratively have them both down pat because
we're going to increase the difficulty right now.
Hey, programmers, Alan here right now.
One To go over the approach for this
tree min value problem. So just like we've been
doing as of late, we're going to have to take in a
binary tree as input into our function. And
we want to do is figure out what the smallest
value within the tree is. That is we want to find
the minimum value. So we can totally assume that
the tree is going to be non empty, right? And
so given that information, looking at this
particular tree example, it's pretty plain for
us to see that the smallest number in the tree
is just this three. Alright, so our function just
needs to return of the number three. So it's plain
to see that the answer is three. But how can we
come up with an algorithm to do this for us? Well,
we should look to our tools in our binary
tree toolbox. And that would mainly just be
either a breadth first or a depth first traversal.
One obvious way to solve this one is to use either
a depth first or breadth first iterative piece
of code that does a traversal and travels through
the tree, then you just need to maintain some
outer variable to track the current minimum.
And whenever you hit a node that is smaller
than your current minimum, then you replace
that minimum variable. And by the end of
the code, you should have the true minimum.
So the iterative version, I think, is pretty
straightforward. And I'll be sure to walk through
that when we get to the code walkthrough. But for
now, in terms of our approach, visual, I think
we'll step through this one recursively, right,
because it ends up being pretty succinct code.
And so let's take a look at this tree. And
let's pretend that we filled in all of the
null pointers, like usual, right? So these dark
nodes over here represent nodes that don't exist,
meaning that there are no, right. So for example,
if I look at the three node, its left child is no,
but its right child is 12. And that's going to be
very useful for us to at least visualize because
I should make a base case about those null
nodes, right? So I know in the long run,
what I want to do is figure out what the smallest
value within the tree is. And so a great default
value for our null nodes would be to return
infinity. And here's the reasoning why I know
that I should not really consider any of the
actual null nodes. And so if I have them return
positive infinity, I know that positive infinity
is definitely not going to be the minimum
compared to any numbers that are actually
within the tree. So we'll start to do is
just fill in all of these infinite values.
In other words, every time we call upon a
null node, or a null pointer, we're going to
return infinity. So I'd fill all of these in.
Now using those infinities as our basis, we
can actually construct our return values.
So looking at this for node to the left, what I
have to do is consider both of its children that
it received, right, and also the value within
the current node. And so what I do is I check,
alright, compared between infinity for an
infinity, what's the smallest value among
them? Well, I know positive infinity is a very
large number. So really, the smallest number here
should be four. And so this call should return
four, right? This node should return for
similar story for this 15 node. Once I have
my left and right return values ready, I do
a comparison with those values against myself,
right? So I check, what's the minimum among
infinity? 15 and infinity, the minimum is 15. I
think it's gonna interesting now that we're at
evaluating this 11 node, right? Now I have some
actual numbers. And so I do this comparison,
right? I compare my left subtree value, which
is four and my right subtree value, which is 15.
And also myself, which is 11. So among 411, and
15. What's the smallest number? Well, that would
just be the four, right? So this node should
return four. And if I do a quick spot check,
this makes some sense, because I have this answer
for above the 11 node, that's telling me that,
within that subtree rooted at 11, the smallest
value was four, which is totally correct.
Now we'll just go ahead and valuate the rest of
this tree. Looking at this 12 over here, I know I
can't evaluate the three because I need a value on
the right hand side ready. So I must evaluate this
12. And I just do the comparison, right? What's
the minimum among infinity 12 and infinity? Well,
let's just definitely 12. Finally, at this three
node, I take the minimum of infinity three and 12,
the minimum there is three. And finally at the
ultimate root, I do the comparison. And I check
what's the smallest among four, or five and
three? And the answer is going to be the three,
right, which is exactly what we expected. And so
just by adding a little variation to our classic
depth first recursion, we can totally solve this
problem. The logic we need to use to combine
our child sub solutions into our main solution
is to just do a comparison, right? So overall,
at every point of this tree, we asked ourselves,
right, given the smallest value in the left
subtree and given the smallest value in the right
subtree. I compare those to myself, and return the
smallest among those three. And then when it
comes to the complexity of this, it's pretty
straightforward. We'll go ahead and say that n is
the number of nodes within our input tree. And we
know that we're going to have a call for every
node of this tree. So that seems to be an O of
n time. In terms of the number of recursive calls,
right, and we know within any particular recursive
call, it sounds like we're just going to do some
conditional logic, right, just find the minimum
among three things. Since three is a constant
number, I'm pretty sure that we're going to
have just an overall time complexity of O of n,
considering the number of calls that we make.
Now, that being said, we'll also have O of n
space complexity adjust due to the call stack
that we use for baseline depth first traversal.
And that seems to be an optimal solution for this
problem. Because what we'll do, we'll go ahead and
code this one up, and I'll catch in the next one.
Hey, programmers, Alvin here, right now I want to
go over a JavaScript solution for this tree min
value problem. And of course, we'll solve this
one a few different ways. I think I'll start by
showing y'all maybe some iterative solutions. And
so we'll just do some classic depth first and also
breadth first, along the way, right. So you know,
you're going to need to iterate or hit every node
within your binary tree. So just go ahead and set
up either a stack or a queue. So I'll choose to
start with a stack over here. So I'll say Kant's,
stack equals empty. And one thing I'll have to be
aware of is looking at the assumptions in the
problem, they tell us that we can assume that
the input tree is not empty. And so that means I
won't need to add a leading if statement checking
if the top level root is null. So I can just go
ahead and initialize my stack with the root node
inside. Cool. And then from there, you need your
main loop to iterate through the different nodes.
So I'm going to loop while my stack is not empty.
So all stack dot length is bigger than zero. Cool.
So if that's the case, and there are still some
nodes to visit, and begin a single iteration of
this algorithm, let's say depth first, by doing
stack dot pop, so I removed the top of my stack,
go ahead and call that my current. And then
from there, of course, we need to check
if our children exist. And if they do, I'll
add them to the top of my stack, right?
So I'll write a pattern like this, I'll say if,
let's say current dot left, that is not equal
to No, then I can go ahead and push that existing
child on the stack, right? So stack dot push,
and I'll push current left retinas a few times by
now should it be second nature, I'll do some same
code for the right hand side. And this is kind
of my baseline of a depth first traversal, right.
But as I look at this current node and its value,
I want to by the end of my loop, have access to
the minimum value within the tree. And so because
I need to find the minimum value in this function,
we're going to use a variable that I'll update
over time, right to track the current smallest
thing I've seen. So I'll initialize this as let
smallest, I'm gonna have to think about a good
default value for this. And so I'll go ahead and
initialize this to actually positive infinity.
So if you're unfamiliar with some JavaScript,
infinity is basically just a number that is
guaranteed to be bigger than all other numbers,
except for itself infinity, right? And the reason
I'm choosing a big number, like positive infinity,
for my default value for the smallest variable,
is because when I see any actual values of my
tree, I know they're guaranteed to be less than
infinity. So these numbers would replace my
infinity, just gives me a good initial value,
right? That's a pretty common pattern, right?
If you're looking for the minimum thing, and
typically your default value is positive infinity.
If you're looking for a maximal thing, then your
default value might be zero or negative infinity,
depending on the problem you're trying to solve.
And so with that default value, where do I
actually want to replace it, right. And I'll
choose to do that right after or something leaves
my stack. That way, you only have to say it once.
If I wrote it, when I added my children into
the stack, what I'm saying twice, right,
which is kind of annoying. So I'll just check,
hey, if current value, so be sure to compare the
actual number value, current value is less than
the smallest, then I've just found a new smallest,
right? So just replace that variable with current
value. Of course, by the end of our while loop,
we should just return that variable, right? And
we should have the true minimum. So let's give
that a shot, run these test cases. And this
is our rendition of an iterative depth first,
right? Awesome. So if you wanted to switch it
up, you know, writing the breadth first is super
trivial in terms of the change we make, you can
just make sure you do stack dot shift, right,
because that would remove the front element
of your queue now and if you push then you're
still adding it to the back. And I guess you
should probably rename this guy to queue.
So very minute difference. Well,
tests that just give that a go.
Cool, passes all of them. Nice. And one thing
to note. So Alex in JavaScript, there is no
immediately when I recorded this video, there
is an immediately available, like optimal queue
data structure just baked in, like you can't
import it through a standard library. And so
when you actually do the array dot shift method,
that line itself is going to run an O of n time,
right, because if you remove the front element of
an array in JavaScript, it will have to actually
shift all the other elements over one position.
In other words, index one becomes index zero,
index two becomes index one, and so on. And so
technically, if you implemented your breadth first
exactly like this, just using a regular array,
and you shift out, then this would probably be
technically like an O n squared solution, which
isn't the fastest, but we'll be able to pass
the specs, typically n squared for most problems
is kind of okay. But you can avoid it if you want
to get the blazing fast solution. But now let's
actually go ahead and implement my favorite
version, which would be a recursive version,
right, which is technically of the depth first.
Right? So we'll say const, trimming value,
chattering min value, dream and value. And
to establish this one recursively will always
start with our base case, right? That's when
you saw these curly guys. So I'll start my base
case, I'll say if my routes is equal to null,
then that kind of means I have the empty tree,
what's like the minimum value in the empty tree?
While that must be infinity, right? For
the same reason we chose infinity before,
right? It's just a good default value,
because I'm going to minimize in the long run.
Cool. And now what I want to do is I want to make
my recursive call. So if I call treeman value
on my left child, and I call it on my right
child, I'll just think about what these
function calls return. Right? Although they're
recursive, if these calls work, they should give
me back the smallest value in the left subtree.
And the smallest value in the right subtree. So
maybe, just to be clear, I'll go ahead
and save the system variables. So I'll say
const, I'll say, left. Min. And also this
should be the right men, right? So I found
the smallest in the left and the smallest in the
right. But I also need to think about myself,
right? I am ru dot Val. So I need to choose the
smallest of root Val left men and Reitman, right,
so you can write like a conditional. So just
some if statements If you want, I think the
best way to implement this in JavaScript is just
to use the math dot min function. So JavaScript,
you always have access to the global capital math
object has a few useful methods on it. One we're
going to find useful right now is math dot min.
If you do that, you can pass in some arguments
and an arbitrary number of arguments. So give
me the smallest between route dot Val and be
sure to access the value because you
need to give numbers to men, right?
Smaller between route dot Val, my left men and my
right man. Cool. And this feels somewhat similar
to the approach drawn we did right where we had
to choose the smallest of these three numbers.
So before we run it, maybe you're unfamiliar with
math dot min, I can quickly demo that for you.
Let's say I had some numbers, we had 10, we
had three, we had six, and we had negative
12. And also 100. And if I console log with that
returns, I'll just run this file as a script. So
I'm not going to execute the tests quite yet.
So I should get negative 12. Because that's the
smallest perfect. And now I think we're ready to
go ahead and test this. So our recursive version,
there we have it. Cool. Alright, so there, we have
our JavaScript walkthrough for this tree minvalue
problem, recommend you practice all of these
different solutions, and then pick a favorite,
maybe just have in your back pocket. That way,
you can always solve this problem in the future,
right. So you should have no issue thinking about
how to solve like a tree maxvalue problem. And by
now, you know, we're getting pretty comfortable
with trees. And typically, we're always going to
fall back to either a breadth first or a depth
first traversal. But in the next few problems,
we're definitely going to look at some spin offs
and some variations on how we can accomplish
more complex logic using these algorithms as
our baseline. So I'll catch in the next one.
Hey, programmers, Alvin here, right now want to
go over this max root to leaf path, some problem,
pretty wordy title, let's take a look at what
this problem asks us to do. So we're going to be
taking in a binary tree as input, and we want to
do is really talk about the paths within this tree
in particular, root to leaf paths. So just to
review, we know that a binary tree typically
for us has a single root and you can identify the
root by just looking at the topmost node, that is
the node with no parent, right? And then also
given this tree there are three leaves, right?
a leaf is a node that has no children. So do
bear in mind right a root has no parent. A leaf
node has no children, some Like 11, and three in
this picture, there are neither roots nor leaves,
right. So it could be the case that a tree has
many leaves, like this tree, right has three
leaves. But a tree for us typically only has a
single root. And so what we want to do is consider
all three of the different root to leave paths,
right, so you must start at the root, and you must
terminate at a leaf. So one of those paths would
just be this one, right 511 for, what we want to
do is consider its total sum. So just summing
the values within the nodes along that path.
If I do five plus 11, plus four, that would give
me a total sum of 20. So that's just one of the
possibilities. If I look at another path, let's
say this path of 511 to five plus 11, plus two
would give me 18. That's another option. The only
other option is is final path from five to one,
five to five plus three plus one. That gives me
a total sum of nine, right? And now among those
three options, I want to choose the maximal path
some right? So that would be a final answer of 20.
So in the long run, we need to come up with
some code that computes the maximal path sum
from the root to any leaf. And that sounds like
a pretty hard problem, right? How can we go about
doing that one? Well, hopefully you notice some
similar patterns, right to problems we've done
previously. So just by looking at the name of this
problem, I'm reminded of a few different patterns,
right? I can think of the tree some problem seems
pretty related here. And can I also think about,
like that minvalue. Problem are, we had
some minimization logic, except now,
I want to maximize something here. And so probably
what I'll have to do in this one is combined some
of my previous knowledge to come up with a pretty
novel solution, but it's okay to rely heavily
on our previous experiences, right. And
so let's start with something classic,
I think we're gonna solve this one recursively.
And in the grand scheme of things, typically,
for tree problems, that is, a recursive code
is usually your best bet when it comes to like,
pathfinding things, right, and building pads and
determining pads. And so we'll take a look at what
we should have our base cases be, if we're gonna
frame this one recursively. So they tell us that,
all right, you need to consider paths, but
not just any paths, right? You always want to
end at a leaf node. So the leaf nodes, like
the ending point, belief, notice the base case.
So my base case is going to be literally about
a leaf node. And recall that that's a node
with no children. So for example, let's say
we had a node as input that had no children,
then what's the total sum of that leaf node?
Well would just be its inner value n, right? So
kind of think about your base cases as if they're
their own inputs, right? As a quick aside, right,
so a totally separate scenario, right? Now, let's
say I gave you a tree that contains only one node,
and its value was 42. And I asked you to, alright,
tell me, what's the maximum path some of this
tree, this tree is very small, right? If you
identify the root in this tree, it's just the 42
node, right? Because it has no parent. And I've
also asked you for the leaves, there's only one
leaf here. And it's also the 42, right? Because it
has no children, right? So the single note of 42,
in this example, is the root and the leaf,
which means that the maximum path, some
would just be 42. Cool. So I'm thinking about my
base cases as if they're their own inputs. Nice.
And what you'd probably recognize here is, in this
scenario, we're kind of considering a base case,
that is not about a null node, right, we will
need at least a separate base case that checks
if we have an actual leaf node. And that's
very, very inherent and given in the problem,
right? They say root to leaf path. Awesome. So if
that's the case, I'm just going to locate all of
my leaf nodes in this diagram. And I know that
they're going to return the values within them.
So just plugging those in, right? And now I can
start reconstructing on my higher level solutions,
right? So given this 11 node, what decision does
this 11 node have to make to compute its answer,
right? So let's read ourselves at this 11 node.
And we have to consider our left and right values,
right. And so if i route myself at 11, the
four represents my max path sum through my left
subtree. And the right hand side to now represents
the max path sum through my right subtree.
Since I want to maximize here, the key
is to just choose between four and two,
right? I choose the bigger of them, right? So
four is bigger than two, so I must use the four.
And what I do is I take that four, and
I add my current value of 11 into it,
and that gives me 15. And that would actually be
the answer for this subtree. In other words, I can
check for correctness right now, if I root myself
at 11. I'm returning 15 to represent this path,
right? I can either do 11 plus four, which
is 15. Or I can do 11 plus two, which is 13.
Right and that 13 is smaller, so I won't prefer
it here. Cool. So so far, it seems like we're
in good shape. Now let's take a look at another
node read to evaluate. Let's look at this. Three
node. So it has a value on its right hand side,
right? It's receiving a one from its right child,
but the left child doesn't exist, right? And
if you want to be a little more explicit,
we know that the left child or three dot left is
going to be a null pointer. All right? So kind of
plug that in here. And here's where we should
work in possibly another base case, sometimes
it's very natural to course correct as we go.
And so for a null node, what should we return?
Well, we know that whenever we have a null node,
it should never contribute to our final answer,
we can kind of just ignore it, I guess, we want
to make sure that it's compatible with the rest
of our internal logic. So bear in mind in this
problem, I want to take the maximum right? Recall
from our previous problem, right, the min
value problem, we want to take the minimum.
And so we made our null nodes return infinity,
right? Because if I want to find the minimum, and
my null nodes, return infinity, by default, I know
that infinity is never going to win a comparison,
right? Because infinity is very large. And we
just want to flip that logic over here, right?
So because in the long run, I want to find
the maximum, I'll make my base case for
the null nodes return negative infinity, right?
Because I know negative infinity is never going
to win any contest where we compare things,
looking for the larger of the values, right?
So for this null note, I'll plug in that
negative infinity. And now I shouldn't be
able to do the same business logic as before,
right? So I'm rooting myself at the three node,
and I can look at the results I get for my
children, right. So between my two children in
my left path, I get a negative infinity, or in my
right path, I get a one, and I choose the maximum
between them, right? One is bigger than negative
infinity. So I should use the one, right. And
what I do with that one is, I add my current value
of three to it. So three plus one gives me four,
right. And that makes some sense, because if
I look at that small subtree, rooted in three,
the biggest path from root to leaf, or sub
root to leaf, I would indeed be a four. Nice,
and now we have ourselves at the ultimate root
over here, I do that similar comparison, right?
I check the bigger of my two children, so I'm
going to keep the 15. But then I add myself to it
giving 20. Like we said before, this 20 logically
represents this path of five plus 11 plus four.
Cool, so there we have it. And if you want to take
a look at the complexity of this seems nothing
unusual. So we're going to have n as the number
of nodes, we're going to have O of n runtime,
because we're going to have to make a call a
recursive call that is for every node within
the tree. And if I think about any particular
call, we're going to make a foreign node,
we're just going to do a comparison, right, I just
choose the bigger of my two children. So we're not
going to have any, any loops within our calls, I
believe. Cool. So it just seems to be O of n time.
Like we always say space complexity is O of n,
just due to the call stack. Nice. So let's go
ahead and code this one up. And it should feel
like a combination of our previous tree some
problems, as well as some a min value max value
logic. Hey, programmers, welcome back, Ryan,
I want to go over a JavaScript solution for this
max root to leaf path, some problem. So this is
going to be a pretty interesting tree problem.
And we'll jump right into the code, please make
sure you watch the approach video before this.
So I think should be all primed up with the logic
that we want to implement here. Right? And so
we'll start by doing this recursively. And I'd
say that's probably the best way to solve this
one. So I think it's the only way I'll show you,
when I want to do is start with a base case,
right? So we said we want to figure out our root
to leaf paths. So our base case should be about
whether I have a leaf, right? So I'm going to
go ahead and check let's say, if my root left is
equal to No, right? And root, right? Is equal to
No, right? That's the definition of a leaf. So if
I have the left child and I have the right child,
then I should return the value stored at this
node, right? So root, dot Val. Nice. So again,
we're kind of emphasizing here is that base
case catches a scenario. If we're at like four,
right, we have no children. Nice. And we will need
another base case in the long run. For now, let's
say we left it like this, right? So we said that
in the context of solving this one recursively,
the decision we make at every note is I choose the
bigger result from my left column A right call,
and then I add myself to it, right? So I know I'm
going to do this recursively so I'm going to call
the same function. And right now you should be
familiar with all right, you call your function on
root left, and also root right? That I think about
what those calls return, right? They give me back,
the max pass some through my left subtree
on the max path, some through my right
subtree I just want to choose the
bigger results between Windows two.
So no I swear to you saw me use the math dot min
function here I'll use the math dot max function.
And I know that these calls these expressions
evaluates to numbers. So I can actually just
pass these guys in, in line. So I would just
move this up like that. So when finding the
max between these two results, and I'll
go ahead and call that we'll say, the
max, your child, right? Maybe I'll write
this online, they prefer. And then from
there, I just add myself to that max
child, right? So I'm going to return
route dot valance myself, plus max child. And
we'll call that max child path. And that should be
it except for one thing we're forgetting. So
take a moment, see if you can read between the
lines here. And what scenario Am I missing? We did
mention it in the approach video. So can you spot
what is not present here? And that's something
I find I do often right? If I'm able to really
come up with a nice, meaningful and consistent
picture, then everything I drew in the picture
should translate to some piece of code over here.
Let's give it a shot. Expect to fail this one.
See what we get? Yeah, so we're getting an
error cannot read property left have no,
right, I found on the very first example.
So I'll tell you that this is caused by an
asymmetric node, like this four over here,
right? This four has no left child. So imagine
what would happen in this instance,
right? So if we're evaluating this code,
we know that our route is going to be this
four node. And this if statement on line 10,
is not hit, right? Because four is not a leaf,
right? Because it has a right child's right
child does not know. So instead, it's going to
run until 11. And it's going to try to execute
max path, some of root dot left root that left is
no. And so when we actually evaluate that call,
now we're seeing is no, and we're gonna check
no dot left over here. And that's going to break
right? It's exactly the line that's broken.
And so in addition to this base case, right,
when we bought him out at a leaf node, what if we
just end up at a null node, so if root is null,
then we said that a good value to return would be
negative infinity, right? Because I'm choosing to,
in the long run, do like maximal logic and want to
pick the max. So if I choose a negative infinity,
that won't interfere with any of us taking a
max, right? Because imagine that this thing
was negative infinity. And I would just prefer
the right hand side if it was not infinity,
right? Negative infinity that is. And so
with that, let's go ahead and give this a go.
Cool. And then we have a nice solution
for our max root to leaf path some
problem. So notice how short the code is,
by no means do I think this is simple code,
though, right? At this point, it's okay if it
feels a little tough. But you understand how we
have some familiar patterns, right, I still
have those two recursive calls right over
here. And we typically only vary in how we take
those recursive calls or the results from them,
and combine them into our higher level answer. So
keep practicing this problem and I'll catch you
in the next one. All right programmers. That wraps
up our course on the introduction to binary trees.
If you want to explore this binary tree topic, or
really any other data structures and algorithms
topic more deeply. Be sure to head destructing
dotnet where we have all of these topics covered
through tons of problems where we have video
walkthroughs and illustrations for every single
problem. I think you'll find this especially
useful if you're repairing and really cramming
for those technical interviews. Thanks
for watching, and I'll see you there.